hello folks
today is Sunday February 18 2018
beautiful day out there in Frankfort and
yesterday's Saturday I got out of
hospital after being in there for three
days I had an operation in fact I had
what the Germans call an audible
I had a two-for-one deal they went in
there and they removed a bladder stone
stump from my bladder if you can see it
in there and it looks like a piece of
limestone there was another little piece
attached that that apparently they threw
away they also went in there and they
according to what the doctor told me cut
a little circle in little I think inside
my prostate and that's been allowed to
shrink
apparently the expanded prostate was
causing the problem with the bladder and
yeah for those of you who wonder about
these things and are afraid to ask the
questions don't look it up on the
internet yeah I can get it up in fact a
lot of people who have prostate
operations because they have cancer so
they have their entire prostate removed
as long as the doctor doesn't touch
their nerves or their muscles keen
nerves and key muscles they can get it
back into production and but that's
that's the part that I didn't see
because thank God for anesthesia
you know the Civil War they used to cut
legs and it was whiskey and like the
handkerchief yeah I didn't get to see
any of that what I did get to see is the
removal of the catheter and that was
that long and a nurses so
good about it she does it in one second
she goes and removes it from the inside
of your penis and I thought I was that
short but no it goes all the way to
kingdom come
and that's not the fun part the fun part
is when you have to go to the bathroom
you know you get all this urine and
blood coming out you know how can I
describe that that's like pouring acid
on a worm and I'll let you try to
visualize that scene but the that's not
the worst part of it the worst part of
it is that I didn't have beer for three
days now that's torture to give you
yogurt healthy foods yeah anyways my son
went in there and filmed before and
after and let me show you what he filmed
you
[Music]
you know it is said that Copernicus
received his famous book the revolution
of us on his deathbed well I didn't
receive my latest book why the
Neanderthals disappeared on my deathbed
I received it only and after bladder
prostate operation and I hope to serves
as an introduction to when unless a nest
which is starting tomorrow Monday I'm
going to be uploading one video per day
for the next couple weeks now I'm gonna
be dealing with the extinction of the
Neanderthals and specifically I'm gonna
be attacking at mixture theory that
mixture holds that and Ethel's
disappeared when they interbred with us
their much smaller population dissolved
essentially in a two-hour big operation
the population and yes I'm gonna be
presenting arguments against that theory
and you know there are people who might
be interested in buying the book and I'm
gonna ask him to hold off I want you to
watch the videos and see if the
arguments make sense to you
I want you to watch the entire series
before you take it to see I don't want
you going out there and saying oh you
know I kind of like this and I you know
spur of the moment you decide to buy it
no I want you to take it easy putting
some beer watch the videos and see what
you think of the arguments and then if
after you're watching them you feel that
you know they make sense and that you're
interested in the subject well then
you'll find instructions on how to buy
the book and my website used to pit
relativist
calm so I'll see you tomorrow and I hope
you enjoy the videos bye
[Music]